[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil y de Cómo
llegan los candidatos a la segunda
vuelta de este domingo en medio de una
campaña plagada de insultos y también
acusaciones que retos tiene que asumir
el próximo presidente brasileño pues se
lo preguntamos a Javier Rincón él es
investigador del centro para la
gobernanza global de la Universidad de
Salamanca y profesor asociado de la
pontificia universidad javeriana Javier
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 y Cómo
llegan los candidatos A esta segunda
vuelta más Cómo ha sido digamos toda la
comunicación política tanto de Lula y de
bolsonaro no que bolsonaro ha tenido la
ventaja en esta campaña se debe a lo que
ha hecho durante todo estos meses
Hola Bueno gracias a ti por la
invitación digamos que la campaña
brasilera ha mostrado la misma tendencia
de todas las campañas no solo en América
Latina sino en el mundo es decir una
campaña donde la comunicación ha sido
tremendamente agresiva y en el caso de
Brasil por el hecho de que evolucionaron
claro ocupa la presidencia de la
república Y tiene pues de alguna manera
la ventaja de ser el presidente que
puede comunicar a través de sus
actuaciones pues resultados que
lógicamente siempre van a impactar en la
campaña electoral pues ha sido una
campaña bastante tensa de hecho creo que
esa situación de agresión finalmente
entre los candidatos ha llevado a que en
este momento los mismos brasileros no
tengan claro uno por quién realmente
votar y dos quien los va a gobernar en
el futuro con un elemento que creo que
es muy muy complejo Y es que derivado de
esa comunicación finalmente tan agresiva
de lado y lado cada uno en sus maneras
muy particulares pues vaya a ser un país
dividido Y quién gane sin importar si es
Luna Silva o el actual presidente
bolsonaro va a tener un gran reto y el
primer gran reto es conciliar a una
sociedad que ellos mismos se encargaron
de dividir durante las elecciones lo
cual me parece tremendamente complejo ya
hablamos Javier de esos retos que
asumiría el nuevo presidente brasileño
pero digamos hablamos de las recientes
encuestas estábamos conversando con esta
corresponsal en Brasil en la ciudad de
de Río de Janeiro nos decía que si las
elecciones fueran el día de hoy Pues
Lula da Silva ganaría con un
53%. antes de la primera vuelta de estas
elecciones presidenciales tenía el Lula
una ventaja amplia sobre bolsonar
evolucionario le recortó esta ventaja a
Lula da Silva Pero bueno si bien
Es cierto que Lula Pues sigue
aventajando este sondeo esta intención
de Voto el domingo podría bolsionar o
revertir todo esto digamos que bolsonaro
tendría el chance digamos de Dios
o podemos ver a Lula como presidente
como lo indican los sondeos desde el
principio no
yo creo que El Punto de partida es
efectivamente la indecisión del votante
brasilero en este momento sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta que hubo una
abstensión muy alta que para un país que
tiene un voto obligatorio pues es
realmente dice muchas cosas más del 20%
de abstención eso quiere decir que en
esta segunda vuelta Pues hay un grueso
de votantes que podrían inclinarse hacia
el hoy presidente bolsonaro no obstante
en mi concepto creo que la tendencia va
a ser muy difícil de hacerla cambiar y a
pesar de que creo que en segunda vuelta
también será como en primera un voto
Finish creo que el ex presidente Lula
mantendrá la ventaja mínima pero
mantendrá la ventaja que tiene de
alrededor de 7 millones de votos creo
que las alianzas que se han hecho entre
los diferentes partidos creo que
adicionalmente el presidente bolsonaro
quemó todas sus naves en la primera
vuelta y no tiene un gran margen ahora
del ni de negociación política ni
tampoco de innovación en cuanto a
propuestas lo que hace que va a ser muy
difícil por lo menos en mi concepto que
él logre acortar Esa diferencia Aunque
la diferencia sea mínima y por el
contrario creo que en esta segunda
vuelta es muy probable dadas las
alianzas que se han hecho no solo entre
partidos sino las propias encuestas lo
que suceda es un fortalecimiento del ex
presidente Lula en las urnas para
segunda vuelta lo cual me lleva a mí a
considerar que lo más probable es que el
domingo quien se proclame como
presidente de la república Federal de
Brasil será Luis Ignacio lunar así bueno
así las cosas Entonces digamos en las
encuestas y en intención de Voto igual
finalmente lo sabremos el domingo
exactitud Quién será el nuevo presidente
pero hablando de este nuevo mandatario
como recibe el país Cómo recibirá el
país el día lunes el nuevo mandatario el
día lunes hipotéticamente el día después
de las elecciones no pero hay que
esperar ahí evidentemente Creo que es el
primero de enero eh el el traspaso de
mando cómo recibir ese país y cuáles son
esos retos de los que estábamos hablando
anteriormente
yo creo que son dos elementos cardinales
el primero es un país dividido y creo
que en general en el mundo y en
particular en América Latina no se ha
querido evaluar lo que eso significa o
sea lo que significa dividir a una
sociedad mediante un discurso político
durante las elecciones para luego
intentar gobernar a esa sociedad
dividida y creo que el primer gran reto
o lo reitero para el futuro presidente
de Brasil es conciliar a esa sociedad
dividida porque nadie puede olvidar que
El perdedor igual tendrá habrá obtenido
alrededor de
50 más o menos mal contado 50 millones
de votos es decir una oposición si lo
queremos decir de alguna manera de ese
talante el segundo reto y gran reto será
conciliar las fuerzas políticas en los
órganos de representación colegiada como
es el senado y la cámara de los
diputados que en el caso de Brasil es
muy compleja porque el presidente
realmente nunca puede hablar de tener
mayorías específicas en una u otra
cámara lo cual hace que además estas
elecciones sean muy interesantes porque
no podemos olvidar que también se van a
elegir autoridades
representativas a niveles de los estados
y creo que el tercer gran reto es y tal
vez otros lo pondrían de una manera
primordial principal es el tema
económico si bien Brasil ha presentado
unos resultados interesantes en los
últimos meses que de hecho el presidente
bolsonaro ha utilizado para
lanzarse un poco más como candidato a la
presidencia Pues realmente creo que el
tema económico es muy muy complejo
porque va a recibir un país como todos
los de América Latina que van a tener
que enfrentar una recesión mundial que
es casi una evidencia